now time really is running out to
finalize a post-brexit trade deal a task
that was made even harder this week
after the eu negotiating team was forced
to self-isolate
due to a positive coronavirus test well
joining us now from paris
is the french mep and the former europe
minister natalie luanto thank you very
much for being on the programme
how optimistic are you that we're going
to manage to
strike a brexit trade deal uh sophie i
have to say i'm a politician
i am neither optimistic nor pessimistic
i am committed
uh we will do everything we can in order
to have a good deal
whether it is possible uh under this
time pressure that you mentioned
honestly i don't know i cannot tell you
uh
it's a done deal uh i will not tell you
we're almost there
because there are still big divergences
but being committed
is the responsibility i have and i'm
happy to carry
um it's interesting isn't it because it
does feel that time really is
ticking down we spoke to simon coveny on
the program
last weekend ireland's foreign minister
who said that the last week just gone
was in his words
move week so has anything actually moved
this week
um well i'm not the negotiator myself so
i will not speak on behalf of michelle
barnier
um some things uh made progress and
ursula van der lion said it a few days
ago
but you know that we are still waiting
for clarity
uh what are we waiting for we want to
build a strong partnership and i think
that the british side does want it as
well we need it on both sides
and if you want to be strong partners
you need to have clarity
on the prospects on the initiative that
your partner is going to take in the
future
and this is what goes under the umbrella
of this
strange world of level playing field we
need to know what sort of
environmental standards you want to have
what are the way you're going to protect
your workers
because we are offering an unprecedented
partnership
with the uk and for very good reasons
but this comes with clarity with
commitments
and so far they are missing and i
think it's really time if we are as
committed on both sides
to reach an agreement that things become
clearer
one of the other big sticking points of
course is fishing a big deal here in the
uk but a big deal where you are in
france
as well after brexit isn't it right that
british fishermen and women should have
access to more of the fish
in british waters nobody is denying
that the waters have are becoming
british
but nobody forgets that the common
fisheries policy
so far has been a success it's provided
with
sustainable fishing and
decent incomes on both sides why
should we ruin something that works
let us try to find a solution which is
sustainable balanced long-term
so that fishermen on both sides don't
pay a price
for a decision which was not taken by
european fishermen
at the same time though you can see why
fishermen and women in
europe might think that the common
fishing policy has worked but if you
speak to
people in aberdeen or in hastings or in
whitstable as i have during the show
they certainly don't think it's worked
they think that their industry has been
decimated because of it
well they were choices which were
sovereignly made because uk has always
been a sovereign nation and that's good
um and in terms of processing uh the
fish products
and you know as well as i do that
british fish products are being
processed
in the european union this is something
that has to be considered
i think we should work on reciprocal
access to waters
as well as reciprocal access to markets
it's in both interests of
the brits and the europeans so let's fix
it
it's interesting because if a deal is
agreed that french fishermen don't feel
gives them enough access to british
walkers there's been
waters there's been talks of blockades
in calais
do you think we could see disruption
well uh i think that it will not happen
because
there has to be a satisfactory fisheries
deal
if there is to be a free trade agreement
this is
the european mandate which was given to
michel barnier
and you're mentioning friends and thank
you for that but we are not the only
fishing uh member state in the european
union
and as you know fisheries is a european
policy so this is something that is
shared by all member states
has been from the beginning of the
negotiation and has been
repeated throughout the negotiation and
it is not intended to
hurt anyone on the contrary it is
intended
to prevent workers to be hurt
by a decision brexit which is supposed
to provide for a better future for the
uk well
we could discuss it but i'm not
discussing it right now but it is not
supposed
to hurt people on the in the european
union we are
partners we are not there to be
adversaries for our future
i think this is the worst thing that we
should do
and may i say as well that i would
definitely like
some uk politicians some british
politicians
refraining from using rhetorics or a
vocabulary as if we were
adversaries fighting against each other
each other
we are struggling to build a strong
partnership for our future this is what
we owe
to our fellow citizens on both sides
talking about disruption and where we
how we have just been
i just wonder what do you think the
consequences of a no deal may be
when it comes to disruption at that
crucial border you know between calais
and dover particularly at a time when of
course many people
are worried about the distribution of
vaccines
well there is absolutely no do no doubt
that a no deal would have bad
consequences
i do hope that the british side is ready
even for a deal because i'm reading and
hearing that even with a deal as there
will be
customs control sanitary controls there
are still
questions and concerns from british
businesses on the
level of readiness on the british side
but let us let's admit that
things are going to improve of course a
no deal would have
bad consequences on the short term
but let's be clear a bad deal
would have bad consequences for the long
term
and a bad deal is a deal and when you
sign it and when you
ratify it you're committed to it so i
really support a good deal and i think
it's
feasible even if time is running out
but i'm not saying that there is no
chance that there could be no deal
uh this could very well happen okay
and thank you very much for coming on
the programme this morning
time of course ticking to get that trade
deal sorted we'll have to find out what
happens in the next week
thank you very much thank you